a former office building on the
outskirts of Amsterdam is where a group
of Somali refugees have found shelter
for the last few months
Laurier Maroma and the other young
Somali women prepare their meals at what
used to be a conference table the Dutch
authorities rejected their applications
for asylum and put the women out on the
street since then they've squatted
various buildings this building used to
house municipal government offices
Maruyama is drying her clothes this is
my bed but before it became my bed it
was actually the computer table for this
room this room was actually an office
for the government municipality office
yeah so those who used to work here were
officials from the same government that
now wants to throw out the refugees but
Maruyama feels she's found a temporary
home
she says she fled from Somali and
Islamists five years ago they asked my
hand in marriage at a time I was 16 and
they came to ask my father to chief to
do that my father refused and it was not
only me but me and my brother and and
when my father refused then they came
several times to him but he still
refused it and if they then at the end
killed him
that's when her brother disappeared
Maria's family decided to send her to
Europe and she landed in Amsterdam the
family probably didn't realize she'd end
up being homeless it's actually our
newest building and before that we have
been in almost ten other I don't know
fourteen other buildings and every time
we occupy a building and they affect us
and we occupy and Derek tasks
hundreds of illegal refugees like
Maruyama are scattered throughout the
city with neither government assistance
nor work permits they can't be deported
because they're without passports and so
they're stuck in limbo the Dutch
authorities refuse to grant us an
interview about the harsh refugee
policies many neighbors show little
interest in the migrants fate few of
them show any empathy we are so in my
heart I say
they are already here try to get no new
ones and the ones that are over the five
six maybe seven years here let them stay
it's not good what will you say that
they have to go back then you have to
send them back but don't let them stay
here they're not good how wonderful to
see him nice to see it is how are you
Mariama couldn't survive without
volunteer helpers like my own sacks a
political scientist she visits the
squatters regularly bringing medicine
when someone's ill but also helping them
find their next shelter Mariama doesn't
understand why the Dutch authorities
treat her so badly if I don't have a
place and they know that they should
give me a place because shelter is not
something that I have to ask it's
something that I'm entitled to it's my
right so if they are not giving and I
try to take it then I don't know why
they have to criminalize me they think
that if they can make the situation very
bad that then you will return and now
it's been proven already for quite a
long time that you well the people who
cannot return are not returning they're
just in very destitute and very bad
circumstances in the street that the
Holland that has been in the past
liberal and and open country has become
very very right-wing and very
conservative and scary in the evening
the refugees hold a kind of conference
and what used to be a government
conference room an attorney is on home
to give free advice she sees only one
way forward the refugees should file new
applications for asylum with additional
evidence to prove they were really
persecuted it's an exhausting
bureaucratic ordeal
this is a declaration or statement that
you don't have any income mm-hmm and if
we send it to the court you don't have
to pay the courts that's the only thing
so what you need then after her five
year long experience with the
authorities
Mariama omar sees no prospects in the
netherlands if i had a choice i will go
back to my country I'll go back to my
cats leaving tomorrow
well it's not possible well I don't have
that choice the situation is similar for
the other refugees here as well but
Holland's harsh Asylum policies have
little deterrent effect and more and
more refugees keep arriving